no kidding
it really is i bless the reigns down in
africa not i miss the reigns down in
africa
i knew that
[Music]
so moonfall is the newest roland
emmerich disaster movie and we've hit
peak crazy at this point the moon has
changed its orbit it's getting closer to
earth at a very rapid pace because the
moon is
not all it seemed to be as it does
destruction ensues they got to stop it
seems pretty impossible but hey this is
a roland emmerich film nothing is
impossible now with being a roland
emmerich film we know what to expect at
this point generally speaking it's going
to go down like this you're gonna have a
lot of dumb fun destructive nonsense
that's pretty sweet when it's going down
and you might have a useless family or
otherwise side character side quest that
bogs the movie down when the movie
concentrates on that in moonfall you get
all of that yeah the destruction was
pretty sweet i mean it's the moon
getting closer to the earth you know so
you got tsunamis tidal waves all that
kind of destruction plus the horizon
when the moon's going over it and you
see bits of the moon breaking off i mean
it's pretty imaginative stuff that make
for a pretty sweet poster i love me some
really good visuals this movie has some
sweet visuals i mean don't go in here
looking for science dude you can't do
that don't i remember i saw neil
degrasse tyson in person who came to
seattle and his whole thing was he was
talking about science and movies and
where movies got it right and wrong feel
like this movie is fodder for that like
neil degrasse tyson could do another
tour and be like okay we can talk about
moonfall now let me get to the bummer
and this movie actually had a lot of
bummers to be honest with you as much as
i liked seeing the destruction that i
saw i feel like i actually could have
seen more don't get me wrong like i said
some sweet visuals in here but the
mission to go to the moon was so
important so at the forefront that it
concentrated on that when
in a story where the moon
is falling to the earth the most
interesting location in the movie is the
earth not the moon that's where the
destruction is going to be going down
and you see a bit of it you do see
glimpses of what i liked for instance
you know getting robbed at gunpoint by
people who want to jack your [ __ ] like
it's the last of us or something i like
that i want to see the decline of
civilization in a situation like this
but it's just you know a scene and a
half it's like the movie was like hey we
got to remind you that that would happen
okay back to the moon stuff and it's
always through the lens of this family
side character side arc that just
bored me i cannot emphasize enough how
much i didn't care about these side
characters i didn't care about the
father-son dynamic which roland emmerich
seems to have a lot of in his movies the
time where the parental child dynamic
worked most the patriot that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] harsh but this movie no didn't
care i was like okay
give me good characters that i actually
do latch onto to show me what's going on
on earth or if you can't have an
interesting group of side characters
have the main character stay on earth so
i can see all the destruction and just
be like uh we died or whatever we failed
[ __ ] the end it works for me when you
look at the movie san andreas san
andreas did a much better job at putting
the characters in peril as they're
traversing the catastrophes that are
happening all around them this movie the
[ __ ] family that i didn't care about
they'll see meteors you know bits of
moon coming down smacking a mountain it
all explodes and they're like all right
stay close i'm like oh yeah stay out of
the way of that inconvenient thing and
you did which means nothing really
happened but when it happened it looked
cool i guess that's the bummer when the
moon crashing into the earth is gonna do
so much to the earth and you don't have
time to show everything it's going to do
in one movie actually even the main crew
patrick wilson and halle berry they were
fine john bradley is absolutely the
standout yeah he thought i was going to
accept john bradley because i omitted
him no i'm saying he is the one i cared
about the most in the movie hands down
not even a contest other than him i
thought everyone else just could have
been
shuffled around with other actors it
wouldn't have made any difference which
is a bummer because in the useless
family side arc of side characters on
earth that i definitely cared about
least michael pena's in there
underutilized and to be honest the
ending left me really unfulfilled
because you have a pretty unique premise
here the moon falling to the earth and
then by the end of this movie this movie
feels way more familiar than it probably
should given what the premise of the
movie is in a world of weighing
positives and negatives there were more
negatives in this movie than positives
for me but hey maybe with enough drinks
you can get past the bogging down that
is to say this movie's probably a better
time if you're drunk yeah no it's a
party this legend of zelda majora's mask
movie really isn't accurate to the game
they have they have like the classic
line i finished it in my head before it
went down here's the setup of the first
line what do you think the follow-up's
going to be
god help you if you're wrong what's the
response you know what it is you know
what it is
god help us all all right so moonfall
have you seen it what did you think
about it what's your favorite disaster
movie out there ever of all time
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you